[Music]
[Music]
today we're taking the new facelifted
gull 7 out for a spin the car comes with
a brand new 1.5 liter TSI Evo engine
replacing the old 1.4 liter TSI engine
the four-cylinder turbo engine also has
an output of 110 kilowatts and comes
with active cylinder management
[Music]
is that not enough you see our contest
in Montes Quran says VW introduced the
Gulf in 1974 and it has been with us now
for seven generations worldwide sales
have top 33 million vehicles that makes
it one of Germany's best-selling cars
ever and Germans simply love the VW Golf
and so it's no surprise VW is unveiling
its latest golf on the island of Majorca
the island is also much loved by Germans
the Gulf's new 7-speed dual-clutch
transmission is said to save up to 0.3
litres of petrol per 100 kilometers this
monthís says this golf is as agile and
easy to handle as its predecessor as its
performance on these narrow winding
roads in northern my Orca shows small
antique ovens the England
[Music]
Malthus can tell the Gulf has replaced
xenon headlights with new full LED ones
in the top-of-the-range version but
halogen headlights are still in the
fewer frills package LED daytime running
lights are now a standard feature so is
the novel front fascia as well as full
LED taillights further options include
animated flowing indicators and chrome
trim panels a digital 12 point 3 inch
active info display instrument cluster
is an optional extra it's fully
customizable drivers can choose which
information they want displayed the
discover Pro infotainment system is
fitted in the center console that comes
with a nine point two inch touchscreen
with optional gesture control and a
customizable homescreen and everyday use
many people will probably prefer using
the conventional touchscreen either way
the discover Pro infotainment system is
intuitive to handle the app connect
system lets you use a selection of
smartphone apps that makes it more user
friendly and safer too but a volume dial
would have been handy
come on my des admits the new facelifted
Gulf seven won't set your pulse racing
but it's a reliable car all VW goals
have been like that customers have come
to appreciate their familiar layout
making the driving experience intuitive
VW do that really well
hospitalist
even a truss bus for V vocalist offered
my thoughts it's
mattis's verdict the Gulf seven is a
great car with a reasonable starting
price of eighteen thousand euros but
this basic version obviously doesn't
come with the high-end features you'll
only have the basic infotainment system
which is now standard but no active info
display and you'll only get a one-litre
three-cylinder petrol engine not the 1.5
liter engine with an output of 110
kilowatts which we tested it's far more
responsive than its 1.4 liter
predecessor either way
the facelifted Gulf remains a really
reliable car mid steam updates as it
gets you on the high-end Gulf seven that
we tested however comes at a hefty price
tag of forty thousand euros in Germany
[Music]
winter adventures in the snow you need a
vehicle with all-wheel-drive to cope
with these extreme conditions and no one
knows how to deal with snow and ice
better than the sweets from the outside
the new cross-country model doesn't look
very different from a standard v90 apart
from its protective body cladding and a
ground clearance of 21 centimetres it
also comes with typical vulval LED
headlights the crossover model aims to
combine design with functionality
our contestant Michelle Austin mother
says she thinks the Volvo v90 cross
country looks just as great inside and
out because it's well-made and feels
good to the touch the digital and
touchscreen displays almost lend the car
a futuristic look this is not completely
new terrain for Volvo the Swedish car
makers brought out their first cross
country model 20 years ago the smaller
v70 XE with the v9 t cross country Volvo
wants to give motorists the freedom to
get out and about in the country without
the need for an SUV
in Norfolk and Michelle says that
driving the v90 cross-country is
practically like driving an SUV the
additional ground clearance means a
higher ride and a better view of the
road and the hood all-wheel drive comes
as standard in the luxury vehicle we're
testing the most powerful diesel d5 pro
with an output of 173 kilowatts it takes
the practically two-ton vehicle 7.5
seconds to accelerate from zero to 100
kilometers an hour and Germany the car
will set you back around sixty three
thousand five hundred euros
therefore monsters are card tester says
the v90 cross-countries road-holding
feels as stable as a train on a track
but it has plenty of go at the same time
as soon as she nudges the accelerator
the car really takes off you can choose
from four different types of engine with
performance outputs ranging from 140 to
200 35 kilowatts Volvo wants access to
as many possible markets worldwide
Michelle says that it's fun to drive the
cross country on normal roads now she's
going to really put it through his paces
and see how it performs in snow and ice
to safely test the car we are using a
special track but first we're going to
switch off the electronic stability
control on rough ground the v90 cross
country becomes a real fun ride
I'll find her car tester says she would
never normally disabled the electronic
stability control function and drive
around on an icy stretch at 30 to 40
kilometers an hour but here it's really
enjoyable and thanks to the all-wheel
drive the car quickly regains control
driven like this the tail does swing out
a bit in the curve but it quickly gets
back on track
you need a sensitive touch but it's
great fun
[Music]
the Volvo v90 cross country isn't just a
safe choice for on-road driving
conditions it's also really fun off-road
this is not just a practical sensible
car it's also a toy for grown-ups
so pretty gums Coulson's
[Music]
British luxury carmaker Bentley is
introducing its most powerful model yet
the 2017 Continental Supersports it's
six litre 12 cylinder engine produces a
whopping 522 kilowatts of power that
propels the car from zero to 100
kilometres an hour in just 3.5 seconds
the new car is also the fastest Bentley
ever achieving a top speed of 336
kilometers an hour the Continental
Supersports is also available as a
convertible prices start at 267 thousand
euros in Germany Honda is bringing out
the 10th generation of its civic compact
on the outside the hatchback has grown
the model is 14 centimetres longer and 3
centimetres wider than its predecessor
it's also flatter combined with its long
wheelbase and short overhangs that gives
the Civic a particularly sporty look
under the hood there's a newly developed
1.5 litre turbocharged gasoline engine
the 134 kilowatt power plant produces a
maximum 240 Newton metres of torque
[Music]
and 2015 Mazda launched the
fourth-generation
mx-5 much to the delight of diehard fans
and new buyers recently the millionth
mx-5 rolled off the assembly line
now the Mazda mx-5 is also available as
a so-called retractable fastback in
Germany the fastback designation derives
from the cars sloping roofline it's
brand-new rear and the highly visible
rear fins give the mx-5 Aref a unique
look aside from this few changes were
made to the design a car tester Amano
Schaeffer says with previous mx-5 models
drivers could simply retract the soft
top by hand that's no longer possible
with the new mx-5 Aref unlike other car
makers who allow you to retract a roof
using your car key mx-5 our F drivers
must push and hold the button on the
centre console to retract the roof
opening up the roof takes less than 15
seconds
the mx-5 RF is currently available with
just one kind of engine it has an output
of 118 kilowatts and accelerates the car
from 0 to 100 kilometers in 7.4 seconds
the mx-5 RF can reach a top speed of 215
kilometers an hour the engine is also
available with a six-speed Automatic
transmission that relieves drivers from
shifting gears though for many that's
one of the joys of driving a roadster
amanwe says he's cruising along at 60
kilometres an hour
it's pretty windy although the side
windows are up he can feel the cold an
outside temperature just seven degrees
Celsius he opted to close the roof but
the car won't let him be a mine wall
can't believe he must slow down to ten
kilometres an hour
besides it's gay now that he slowed down
our tester can closed the roof he's not
impressed
Amano would much prefer to operate the
roof up to speeds of 50 or at least 30
kilometers an hour scene doesn't Sabinas
but that's a minor quibble considering
this is Mazdas first fully automatic
roof the mx-5 ahrefs interior has a
refined sporty quality just like the
mx-5 soft top convertible and of course
like any proper roadster the mx-5 RF
comes with a manual handbrake it also
has bucket seats with red decorative
elements there a standard feature few
additional options are available for the
mx-5 RF the exception a sat-nav system
and a tech package that includes Park
distance control both are available for
700 euros but real roadster fans will
surely be content without these
additions the mx-5 RF is much quieter
than the mx-5 soft-top version that's
because Mazda has added extra insulation
to the body and roof making for a more
enjoyable driving experience
amano says he's never been a fan of
soft-top convertibles which is why he's
really pleased with the mx-5 RFR top he
admits that it's a little more expensive
than the soft-top version and that
opening and closing the roof is not
quite so simple but he manoa much
prefers the mx-5 ahrefs new sporty
design which outshines the mx-5 soft
Anita gosh Porsche want kylajo stay no
malice off-topic sphere and Germany the
starting price for the mx-5 RF is just
under twenty nine thousand euros
[Music]
in the highly competitive van market
three manufacturers said to impose oh
and Toyota have combined forces and
designed a new generation of MPVs
thus advanced paste or the Pujo traveler
and Toyota Pro ace share the same
platform and technical features the main
differences are aesthetic the front end
does sit two N's MPV looks friendly
but brawny the typical chrome grille
emphasizes its girth
the van currently comes in two different
body lengths we're testing the shorter
one in the range which measures almost 5
meters at first glance the tail end
looks pretty classic in design but it
includes a practical feature when you're
parked in a tight space you don't need
to open the entire tailgate fully to get
access to the interior so car tester
vinyl Dyson over says even the rear
window opens that's handy when you're
loading up the French manufacturers also
had some clever ideas inside there's
lots of storage space and a rotary gear
selector we're testing the top trim
level shine safety features include a
Driver Alert and a collision warning
system the head-up display projects key
information into the drivers field of
vision at the press of a button the
sliding doors open our model carries
seven people comfortably but it can seat
up to nine there are also practical
folding tables in the second row
[Music]
[Applause]
long few thousand the speech tour has a
maximum of four thousand five hundred
litres of cargo space as kind hold and
yet at one point nine meters in height
its low enough to fit into an
underground parking garage inside
there's a full leather trim and
individual rear seats that makes the
space - a real alternative to the
Volkswagen multi van there are four
diesel engines available we tested the
most powerful a 2-liter diesel with an
output of 130 kilowatts it could reach
speeds of 170 km/h average fuel
consumption is 5.7 liters per 100
kilometers and Germany this particular
van would cost over 51,000 euros the
lowest end version would set you back
some 35,000 euros as with any
manufacturer anyone who wants a high
spec for their vehicle will have to dig
deep into their pockets
[Music]
classy car expert Christophe Bauer is
taking a renault 4cv out for a spin it
was the first French car to sell more
than a million units during World War
two louia will know and some of his
engineers covertly created its concept
and design this stuff says Louie Renault
had already built his first car back in
1898 together with his brothers he
founded the company socia terribly no
fair before the Second World War they
were considered specialists at making
trucks and watch three cars and during
the German occupation that their mark
forced them to build utility vehicles
after the war renault was nationalized
and focused on bringing mobility to the
masses soon it had just the right
vehicle to do that there are no 4cv
Louie Renault didn't live to see the 4cv
make its debut and 1944 he was accused
of collaborating with the Nazis and
arrested he died in prison while
awaiting trial
but Louie Reno's final creation sold
like hotcakes customers waited up to 36
months for delivery of their 4cv
though for many it wasn't exactly love
at first sight
first off says the 4cv was ridiculed
when a debuted at the Paris Motor Show
in 1946 the public dubbed it la mort de
beer or the lump of butter due to its
shape and sand yellow color the color
was chosen for cost reasons as we know
still had lots of surplus paint once
used for the army vehicles of the German
Afrika Corps in Germany the 4cv had a
nicer nickname the cream cake due to the
success of the 4c veera knows Factory in
Boulogne alone crew was transformed into
one of the most modern car plants in
Europe within two years production rose
from 12 vehicles per day to 450 and
France the innovative 4cv was loved by
everyone large or small
yeah but that kappa birthday whoo
no it's nothing Christophe says that
even in 1960 15 years after was first
introduced a German car magazine praised
the 4 CV as an exemplary full-fledged
small car it's easy to handle and
operate is well laid out well made and
comfortable enough at normal speed to
run smoothly and handles well
only when pushed to its limits does the
car demonstrate the twitchy handling
typical of rare engine models but he
notes that in the right hands the four
CV even works as a race car that had
class victories in the 24-hour Lamar the
Mille Miglia
and the Monte Carlo Rally still the
renault 4cv had to be one of the most
unlikely race cars of all time
Christophe says so-called suicide doors
were common in the auto industry until
the 1950s and on this four-door Renault
the hinges for both the front and rear
doors are attached to the b-pillar not
only does it look good it also reduces
weight and costs so do the simple vent
windows in the Spartan seats the cars
progressive elements included its
hydraulic brakes and its monocoque body
whose shape resembles the VW Beetle
hardly surprising given that streamlined
styles were in vogue both in Germany and
France at the time the renault 4cv is a
little masterpiece of engineering it's
almost three point seven meters long yet
weighs less than 600 kilos and it's a
four-door model which seats four
comfortably the workmanship is of high
quality and all of its details are well
thought out the 4 cv may be simple in
design but there's nothing cheap about
it
[Music]
as I'm been school Krishna loves this
wonderful lever which opens up the front
hood though here there's nothing to see
but a spare tire and a bit of luggage
base that's because the motor is at the
rear
just like with a VW Beetle though the
4cv has a water-cooled four-cylinder
engine not an air-cooled boxer
christophe says the ancient is reliable
easy to maintain and most importantly it
can run at full throttle
[Music]
depending on its production year the
long-stroke 750cc engine generates 1721
or 33 horsepower with this 21 horsepower
model drivers who work their way through
the partially synchronized transmissions
three years can go from zero to 100
kilometres an hour and 56 seconds but
that's pretty much as fast as the car
will go Christoph says at first the
French were skeptical but they soon grew
to love the 4cv so apart from a few
minor alterations the model remained
basically unchanged until production
ended in 1961 one million one hundred
five thousand of them rolled off the
assembly lines a four cv was the first
french car to sell over 1 million units
ahead of cinta wants to cv
in Japan the 4cv was still produced
until 1963 here the little car was built
under the license as the key no renault
4cv but it was affectionately called the
tortoise first off says the 4cv saw the
light of day a few months after the VW
Beetle went on sale together with cid
twins 2cv a 4cv did for France what the
beetle did for Germany it brought
mobility to the masses it also
established the tradition of building
rear ancient cars at Renault which
continued into the 1970s so he feels the
renault 4cv is definitely a milestone
and automotive history for 15 years from
1946 to 1961 the 4cv remained a modern
mode of transport its successor was the
renault for a very different but also
very successful model 8 million renault
4 is rolled off the assembly line over
the course of 30 years but it was the 4
cv that established from those
reputation as a compact car specialist
[Music]
[Music]